On Discovery.com, I learned that most meteors
burn up in Earth's atmosphere.
AHH the ATMOSPHERE!
AHhhhhh! ahhhhh.
// But what happens to those that don't?
Hello Meteor.
Trace here for DNews.
Meteors and missiles can hit the ground with
massive force.
The 1908 Tunguska Impact in Siberia flattened
2,000 square kilometers of Russian forest
with an explosion 1,000 times greater than
the bomb dropped on Hiroshima.
The meteor left a crater, likely created local
firestorms raised by superheated air, and
particles from the impact may have cooled
Earth's climate,!
Tiny things hit planet Earth all the time,
but they're usually not fast enough or large
enough to worry anyone.
Observations from satellites suggest anywhere
from 1 to 300 metric tons of dust hit the
Earth, every.
day.
Assuming 100 tons, evenly across the whole
surface we'd gain around point zero two nanometers
every year to the radius of our planet.
You can see some of these things as they fly
through the atmosphere - anything over 2 millimeters
in size can create a streak of friction-spawned
burnup.
We call them shooting stars, but they're just
dust and bits of rock.
If a meteoroid is large enough to make it
through our atmosphere and dent the solid
surface of our planet -- at least the size
of a marble -- then it gets real.
Most of us know what happens to the stuff
ON the surface, destruction, dust clouds,
etc; but new research from Duke University
simulated high-speed impacts on sand and soil
so now we know what happens UNDER the surface
too.
They based it on missiles, but it works for
meteors too.
When an object hits the surface at high speed
the soil doesn't move out of the way, but
actually solidifies.
Think of it like a crowd of people, or a pack
of snow -- the faster you try to move through
the mass -- the more difficult it becomes.
The researchers dropped a metal rod with a
rounded end onto a pack of beads designed
to simulate soil.
They varied the strength of the beads to simulate
speeds from 67 to 670 miles an hour (6 to
300 m/s) and found as it sped up, more of
the beads took the force of the impact, more
quickly, spreading the kinetic energy over
a wide area of soil.
As the projectile speed increased, the particles
of soil couldn't get out of the way fast enough,
When you think about it, this isn't a staggering
discovery, but it's useful for the production
of bunker busting missiles -- it was funded
by the Defense Threat Reduction Agency,.
AND it shows why, when a meteor hits the ground,
it doesn't just burrow into the planet.
All that kinetic energy dissipates through
the soil at such a rapid rate, and creates
a blast crater.
And in case you're wondering if ALL that energy
could change the orbit of our planet, Earth
is real big, y'all.
We're orbiting at around 67,000 miles an hour
(108k kph) and we're quite massive.
If you were to blow a 100 mile-thick (160km)
chunk of North America off the face of the
Earth; we'd only alter the Earth's momentum
by about 50 miles an hour (80kph).
Meteoroid strikes like the Tunguska event
do happen every 50 to 100 years or so, so
we'll likely see one in our lifetime!
And now you know what's going on both above
AND below that crater.
We got some awesome questions last time we
asked, so we're asking again, what do you
want to know about science?
What should we talk about in a future DNews?